hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan
today I mention a question from one of
my forum leaders named Justin who wrote
in asking please share your suggestions
regarding motivation and how do you
personally keep yourself and your
employees motivated so thanks for the
question Justin a really big problem
that a lot of entrepreneurs face I think
every entrepreneur goes through periods
where they think about giving up I think
it's you know not a good idea to keep
going and and you got to go through
those dark days it's one of those dirty
secrets of entrepreneurs that we don't
really talk about a lot you know we're
always saying all the good things about
our business and all the momentum that
we've built but we don't really talk
about how depressing it can be and how
we think about quitting and giving up
and I think again I think every
entrepreneur goes through that at least
at least once and often multiple
multiple times thinking about just going
to get a job and just leaving what
you're doing behind this is too much
work and frustration in terms of what
keeps me motivated what really helped at
the beginning was how I first started
helping entrepreneurs was I was doing
worksheets or workshops sorry so I would
go and do presentations entrence would
come and listen to me and I thought it
was a lot of work and but I really
enjoyed it and I kind of psych myself
out sometimes where before going to
think ah you really want to do this you
know it takes a lot of time but then it
always got a big high afterwards and so
I try to remind myself of all the
positive things that came out of it and
I think the two things that can help you
when you're looking at staying motivated
the first is make sure you think about
the future life that you're trying to
create for yourself so why did you start
your business right there's a reason why
you started it up it's probably to make
a little bit of money but also hopefully
to help people and improve their lives
right if it's just to make money you're
probably not gonna be successful you
want to do something that is gonna
enrich the lives of other people as well
and so whenever I feel down I try to
remind myself of that future life that
that I'm trying to create there's
especially when I was first getting
started and if sometimes find it hard to
get out of bed and get going and do your
work you know when you have a boss your
have to get into work and you have to go
in and you know do your job or you might
get fired but when you're up when you're
your own boss it can be a lot harder to
get that motivation so trying to you
know just remember every morning that
I'm trying to build this life for myself
and I'm trying to help other people and
that kind of gave me a little bit of
extra motivation also trying to get
frustrated with the current situation so
if you're angry that you can't pay your
bills or you can't afford you know
whatever product or service you're
trying to go out and buy that can get
you frustrated give you the motivation
to get going and actually you know take
action the other thing that I found
really helpful for me and this is what
keeps me going now is feedback from
customers so again hopefully you're
building a business that is helping
people and providing a really you know
value add product or service that
improves the lives of other people and
if you're doing that you should be
getting positive feedback from the
customers and for me this is what keeps
me going every day I wake up you know if
I open up my computer I see some notes
from email or social media and people
writing in saying how much they love the
videos or my newsletter or my worksheets
and how it's impacted their lives and
it's you know change their perspective
and giving them new motivation that
keeps me going and you know when you
guys leave comments on the YouTube
videos I want to make more YouTube
videos and same thing with the
worksheets and the newsletter and so I
get that on a daily basis coming in from
all of you guys so thank you like that
keeps me wanting to wake up and do more
for you and so you may not have
immediate feedback yet if you're just
getting started but try to think of some
of the people you've helped maybe you
make a PowerPoint presentation that you
watch in the morning or you just print
off some of the quotes and have the
clothes to your desk about some of the
people you've helped and how you've
impacted their lives and at least for me
I found that really motivating to want
to go and do more you know one of the
greatest joys I think that you can get
in life is helping other people and when
you do it you get a natural Racha high
that you want to go and do again and so
the more you can remind yourself of that
by having some visual cues you know
quotes or pictures from people who you
have helped the more you know easy it is
to go out and want to do it again and
stay motivated but it is tough and so
don't get discouraged if sometimes you
feel down about
business and your life you know it it
happens it's very common but try to make
sure you do something every day to grow
your business and move it forward in
terms of motivating employees what I
found really helpful is two things one
trying to tie them into the bigger
picture of what they're doing so we have
a mission at Evan Carmichael calm we
want to help you know billion
entrepreneurs and there's multiple
people on my team and they all have a
role in helping me do that but they
don't always see how their role ties
into the bigger picture and I think a
lot of entrepreneurs face that challenge
with their team is the staff members
they do their job that could be great
team members but the more you can show
them how their specific task ties into
the bigger picture of helping people the
easier it is for them to stay motivated
often it's easy for the people who are
on the front lines so people who are
dealing with their customers and they're
seen that the positive feedback that's
coming back for them that's that's
easier because they're getting a lot of
positive momentum there but for the guys
in the back end you know like your
programmers or the guys creating the
product your engineers who don't see the
final result and they don't see your
reaction the customers it's helpful to
help tie them into how what they're
doing is helping people and so the more
you can do that the the easier it is to
get them motivated to keep going and
grow themselves the other thing that I
find really helpful leaps from my team
is I get most of the positive stuff in
the business and my team deals with most
of the the crap in the business I think
as entrepreneurs we we you know try to
do the things that we'd like doing and
give off the stuff that we don't and
what I mean by that is all the support
issues all the emails that come in
people asking questions or people having
problems that it doesn't usually come to
me it goes to my team and they'll help
them solve and they do a great job of
doing that when the email so you come to
me are the ones from you guys you're
watching the videos seeing how you know
how great it's been how it's impacted
your life so I usually got all the
positive emails and so what I try to do
is share those with the team so they're
not just getting all the bad emails or
that the support emails are the question
emails but also the emails from you guys
saying how much we've had an impact on
your lives and your businesses and I
find doing that on a regular basis so I
do it monthly
like stats on what we're doing and I'll
send everybody on my team an overall
email of how we did for the past month
how we're doing to accomplish our major
goals and then also some of the we call
them Wow emails but emails that have
come in from you guys who have said how
much we've had a positive impact and
that gives them a better sense of how
they tie into the bigger picture as well
as how we're helping people and the
positive things that we're doing so
makes me feel good about themselves and
want to keep going so hopefully I'll
help the good question I know it's a big
challenge for entrepreneurs but you know
don't get discouraged do something every
day to make your business go forward and
eventually all those little steps will
turn into big steps that you look back
and you'll be amazed of what you can do
so thank you for the question for those
of you watching if you like the video
you know what keeps you motivated if
when you leave comments and thumbs up so
I really appreciate those and if you
have a question about your own business
or about this video feel free to leave
in the comments below I always read
those and your questions are what become
these new videos so feel free to leave
one below thank you and I'll see you in
the next episode
you